[Musique]
comment les pesticides utilisés dans les
vignobles affecte-t-il les riverains la
question est au coeur d'une enquête
nationale inédite de santé publique
depuis plusieurs années l'impact des
produits phytosanitaires sur les
riverains des vignes française suscite
des inquiétudes les premières alertes
remonte aux années 90 on a eu un gros
nuage qui nous est arrivé dessus
directement sur la table sur tout le
monde en 1991 pour les riverains des
parcelles viticoles de chignin en savoie
il n'y avait déjà aucun doute les
pesticides déversées à côté de leur
habitation impact est leur santé
managers médecins elle a rendu toute la
nuit j'ai dû faire venir le médecin et
il a constaté doncker vraiment qu'ils
étaient très forts vomissements début
2000 la communauté scientifique se
penchait sur le phénomène les premières
études émergé comme ici au chu de
montpellier
plusieurs cas de malformations génitales
sur des enfants étaient observés le lien
avec les pesticides était alors
sérieusement envisagée il est apparu que
pour une dizaine de familles dont les
nouveau nés et des porteurs de ces
malformations génitales le père ou la
mère quelques fois même les deux et
exercer une profession dans le milieu
agricole il s'agissait soit de
viticulteurs soit de riziculteurs qui
reconnaissait eux-mêmes utilisé
largement des pesticides autre étude
autre alerte celle de l'association
écologiste générations futures en 2013
les cheveux de 25 personnes vivant ou
travaillant à proximité des vignes
étaient analysées résultat les cheveux
des riverains contenait cinq fois plus
de pesticides que les personnes vivent
loin des vignobles un constat effarant
pour le porte parole de générations
futures
c'est quelque chose qui est important
une réelle information ça montre que les
pesticides qu'on va mettre dans l'air en
pulvérisant près des habitations ils
sont ingérés par les gens et qu'on les
retrouve dans leur organisme et ce sont
des produits dont on sait qu'ils sont
suspectés d'être cancérigènes qui sont
des perturbateurs endocriniens ou des
produits qui touchent pas immédiatement
mais sur le long terme à force on
mélange peuvent favoriser un syndrome de
pathologies la même année des cas de
cancers d'enfants étaient signalés à
preignac en gironde l'école primaire
étaient situés à proximité d'une
parcelle de vigne en 2015 un rapport de
la rse reconnaissait que les enfants de
la commune était six fois plus atteints
de cancer que la normale sans établir de
lien direct avec les pesticides pour
l'ancien maire il n'y avait pourtant
aucun doute il ya une multiplication des
cancers sur pagnac
il est mort j'ai des très bons copains
qui sont morts chez les hommes au
conseil municipal on est 20 % à voir des
cancers de la prostate
d'autres études locales feront le lien
entre pesticides et risques sur la santé
la nouvelle enquête sur l'exposition des
personnes vivant en zone viticole
devrait donner un aperçu nationale les
résultats sont attendus pour 2024
[Musique]